♪ ♪
>> Tammy: UNLIKE LARGE PARTS
OF THE WORLD, AMERICA HAS NEVER
IMPLEMENTED SOCIALISM, BUT COULD
THAT BE ON THE BRINK OF
CHANGING?
TUCKER RECENTLY HAD A
CONVERSATION ON THAT TOPIC.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED.
SPEAK TO AMERICA'S ECONOMIC
SYSTEM IS IN TROUBLE AND HAS
BEEN FOR MORE THAN A DECADE.
I'D NEVER FULLY RECOVERED FROM
THE FINANCIAL COLLAPSE OR NOT
HAS BEEN TRUE REGARDLESS OF WHO
HAS BEEN IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
MIDDLE-CLASS IS DECLINING.
THAT TREND DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
SLOWING DOWN.
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT WILL
REPLACE OUR MIDDLE-CLASS?
JOEL KOTKIN JUST WROTE A
FASCINATING PIECE FOR THE
"ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER."
HE PREDICTS THAT AMERICA IS
HEADED FOR A REGIME OF
OLIGARCHICAL SOCIALISM OR
SUPERRICH BUSINESS LEADERS LIKE
MARK ZUCKERBERG BUY OFF THE
MASSES WITH PROGRAMS LIKE A
GUARANTEED MINIMUM INCOME.
JHAREL COTTON JOINS US TONIGHT.
JOEL, THAT WAS A FASCINATING
PIECE, A DYSTOPIAN PEACE, A
TERRIFYING PIECE.
I HOPE YOU ARE WRONG IN EVERY
DETAIL.
WHAT IF YOU ARE NOT?
TELL US WHAT THAT WILL LOOK
LIKE.
>> I USUALLY DON'T THINK I AM
WRONG.
[LAUGHS]
I THINK WHAT IS BASICALLY
HAPPENING IS THAT WE HAVE A VERY
SMALL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE
UNPRECEDENTED WEALTH AND PART OF
THE ECONOMY, AND CONTROL OVER
MEDIA LIKE WE HAVE NOT SEEN
BEFORE.
AND THEIR BUSINESS MODELS ARE
NOT UNIONIZED, THEY GENERALLY
HIRE A LOT OF THESE FIRMS HIRE A
LOT OF PART-TIME WORKERS,
THEY HIRE A LOT OF PEOPLE FROM
OVERSEAS, AND SILICON VALLEY,
SUCH AS 40% OF THE TECH
WORKFORCE.
WITH A DON'T WANT TO DO IS PAY
THE BENEFITS AND THE PENSIONS
THAT THE EVIL COMPANIES, LIKE
OIL COMPANIES AND
MANUFACTURING COMPANIES DO, TO
THEIR EMPLOYEES.
SO WHAT IS THE SOLUTION?
WELL, IF I WANT TO BE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, WHAT I DO IS I
TALK ALL THE GOOD TALK ON GENDER
AND RACE AND CLIMATE AND ALL
THAT, AND I PUT OFF THE BURNING
PEOPLE BY SAYING, OH, WE'LL HAVE
FREE THIS, READ THIS, FREE
EDUCATION, AND A GUARANTEED
INCOME, AND RENT SUBSIDIES, AND
BY THE WAY, HOW ARE WE GOING TO
PAY FOR IT?
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TAKE
$100 BILLION FROM JEFF BEZOS, SO
HE'D ONLY BE STUCK WITH
$50 BILLION.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE IT FROM
YOUR AVERAGE UPPER-MIDDLE-CLASS
HOUSEHOLD OWNER AND THAT IS WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE IN CALIFORNIA AND
I THINK THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE
GOING TO DO NATIONALLY.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO ATTACK THE
OLIGARCHS, THEY ARE GOING TO
ATTACK THE UPPER-MIDDLE-CLASS,
WHICH IS WHERE THE MONEY IS.
>> Tucker: I GUESS I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY CONGRESS HAS SAT
PASSIVELY BY AND ALLOWED THIS TO
HAPPEN.
ON THE LEFT, YOU THINK THERE
WOULD BE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
RIGHTS OF MIDDLE-CLASS WORKERS,
AND ON THE RIGHT, THEY WOULD BE
CONCERN ABOUT, I DON'T KNOW,
MONOPOLIES, CONCENTRATIONS OF
POWER THAT ARE UNPRECEDENTED IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
BUT NO ONE EVER SAYS ANYTHING
THAT YOU JUST SAID.
WHY?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, TAKE A
LOOK AT THE TWO PARTIES.
REPUBLICANS ARE BASICALLY A
BUNCH OF SPECIALS BE HONEST
HONEST ABOUT IT.
YOU JUST PUT A FEW DOLLARS UP
AND THEY WILL FOLLOW IT.
THESE GUYS HAVE LOTS OF MONEY SO
THEY CAN BUY THEM OFF.
THE LEFT HAS A MORE COMPLEX
SITUATION BECAUSE, WHEREAS,
THERE ARE SOME PRINCIPLED PEOPLE
ON THE LEFT WHO WILL TAKE THESE
OLIGARCHS ON, LIKE
BERNIE SANDERS, FOR INSTANCE, A
LOT OF THEM ARE ALLIED, THAT IS
WHERE THEY GET THEIR MONEY.
THEY GET THEIR MONEY FROM
WALL STREET, THEY GET THEIR
MONEY FROM THE TECH OLIGARCHS,
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHERE THE
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS ARE
GOING.
SO THE PROBLEM IS, HOW DO YOU
HAVE A DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT IS
BASICALLY MADE UP OF THE RICHEST
PEOPLE IN SOCIETY AND HOW DO YOU
SERVE IN THE MIDDLE CLASS AND
SERVE THOSE PEOPLE AT THE SAME
TIME?
WELCOME OF THE WAY YOU DO WOULD
COME IF YOU CHANGE THE NATURE OF
THE MIDDLE-CLASS.
THE MIDDLE CLASS NO LONGER OWNS
A HOME, PROBABLY HAS A FAMILY,
IS A RENTER FOR LIFE, LIVING IN
THE LITTLE APARTMENT, AND, BY
THE WAY, WILL VOTE RELIABLY
DEMOCRATIC BECAUSE BASICALLY
THEY ARE GOING TO BE COMPLETELY
DEPENDENT ON THE GOVERNMENT FOR
THEIR LIFESTYLE AND FOR THEIR
RETIREMENT.
>> Tammy: THAT MAKES MY HEART
BEAT FASTER.
IT MAKES ME SO MAD.
WE NEED A TEDDY ROOSEVELT, THE
FLAMING SWORD OF JUSTICE TO
RESTORE THE AMERICAN MIDDLE